[Music]
my name is john benjamin and my
characters sterling Archer
Cody special skills
um rested behavior insulting and Krav
Maga Maga McGraw Maga from Maga not
McGraw he does not do that Turkish ship
personality flippin privileged to me
mate spirit him nah salon smells like
I'm over something climb alcohol
consumed per week in leaders oh dear
you're on the European model now in Des
Moines 714 leaders strength Brett and
speed Jewish intelligence six six out of
ten
no study secret secret intelligence
stamina
for sex less than a minute catchphrase
get with the USA my name is Aisha Tyler
I play lana kane on archer code name
code named hot special skills
the ability to eat three servings of
surf on stir-friday the ability to wear
the same outfit every day without dying
a humiliation or boredom ability to ride
public transit with two tech nines you
know how black woman's getting away with
that personality super foxy awesome
spirit animal Fox with
three X's and a wide smells like
chocolate chip cookies bourbon and
freedom alcohol consumed per week in
leaders 1.5 liters of American whisky
which incidentally is 1.2 percent of the
alcohol that Archer consumes a string on
a scale of 1 to 7 Lana's strength is an
onion damn business
speed on is like mr. Miyagi catch a fly
with chopsticks engage in ridiculous
racial stereotypes fast intelligent I
actually can articulate it with words
would be a series of quick symbols
violent gear
stamina a lot obviously has a lot of
stamina patiently trying to sustain some
kind of a human relationship with our
turn
catch brings my vulva is smooth as a
veal cutlet my name is Jessica Waldron
my character is Malory Archer code name
and special skills many special skills
personality brilliant cunning wise
spirit animal my god spirit animal is a
cheetah
it smells like pine I am over something
fine alcohol consumed per week in liters
seven strength 12 speed 15 intelligence
22 stamina 50 plus catchphrase idiots my
name is Chris Parnell I play Cyril
Figgis codename the owl special skills
it was really good with math and
accounting logic issues are pretty
pretty good for him
and he's not a bad actor personality
timid brave and summer spirit animal the
monkey smells like peppermint forest or
some banana alcohol consumed per week in
leaders comes through about a half a
liter he's not a big drinker strength
moderately strong he's not this
strongest most men speed he's not as
fast as most intelligence he is more
intelligent than Hospital stamina the
stem was pretty great pretty good
cardiovascular system catch phrase
suppressing fire
I'm lucky Yeates I play dr. Krieger code
name tentacles special skills his
special skills be in your pal when the
chips are down personality chaotic
neutral spirit and glowing pig smells
like sadness and despair alcohol
consumed per week in liters liters five
strength 9 he's not a 9 a is like a 4
speed is speed 2000 intelligence 8
billion stamina stamina a Creed and that
is on a scale of 1 to 8 billion catch
bring me - I'm amber - and my character
is Pam Bouvier codename it should be
sweet tips special skills she can fight
drive drift cars do tattoos and street
art personality badass super cool
dangerous spirit him if a cheetah had a
baby with a grizzly bear
smells like she smells like whiskey and
Cheetos alcohol consumed per week and
leaders 25 liters strength oh my god
Pam is totally a 10 on a scale of 1 to
10 and strength speed to intelligence 8
stamina 10 catchphrase
holy shitsnacks great awesome guys that
was super fun okay